did you pick up the rear elises of  Resident Evil 4 5 and 6 well you're not  alone I'm Tony and this is your  top-selling GameSpot news update the  newest resident evil titles were  released in HD on ps4 and Xbox one this  year and capcom announced in a tweet  that they've now shipped 1.5 million  copies worldwide Resident Evil 6  released in march five released in june  and four released in august all priced  at twenty dollars each considering the  staggered release dates they probably  don't have equal shares of those 1.5  million sales but it's still a great way  to mark the series 20th anniversary  Capcom is no stranger to HD re-releases  remastered versions of Resident Evil 1  and 0 are also available and a remake of  2 is on the way Capcom says you can  expect even more so stay tuned to  gamespot for more coverage on those and  for all the biggest Resident Evil news  you're already in the right place